david tennant is one of the most beloved
actors around with acclaimed turns as
the doctor
and detective alec hardy on broadchurch
so why haven't you heard from him lately
it isn't like he stopped working
he has stayed pretty busy but with
projects you might not have seen
don't get us wrong we're not here to
judge in fact if
the only tv show you regularly watch or
pay attention to is doctor who
you might be doing something right
launched in 1963 the ongoing adventure
of the time and space traveling
do-gooder known as the doctor remains an
intensely influential sci-fi institution
in part this is by virtue of having
existed for so long
if a person feels like watching doctor
who and absolutely nothing else that
person could certainly manage that
without boredom
ever presenting itself as a major
problem tenants three seasons alone
could tide one over for a while tenant's
tenth doctor appears in at least
two of the best doctor who episodes of
all time blink and
the girl in the fireplace his run didn't
just wow
fans it reinvigorated doctor who as a
whole
so if this is still what you know tenant
best for
well you've got taste but if it is in
fact your preference to watch
nothing except doctor who it explains
why you haven't heard from the man in a
while as he hasn't
regularly been on the show since
president obama's first term
we should clarify that when we say david
tennant does not appear
regularly on doctor who we're referring
to the bbc television program
but while his time as a physical
presence on the tardis ended in 2010
his time as the doctor continues to this
day the 10th doctor joins forces with
tom baker's indispensable fourth doctor
with their original actors voicing both
characters in the audio drama
out of time released in august 2020.
this is enormously exciting for fans
the fourth doctor who baker portrayed
from to 1974-1981
still stands as one of the most widely
recognized versions of the character
but this production is actually not all
that out of the ordinary for tenant who
records doctor who audio dramas all the
time
in fact it just so happens that doctor
who related projects
only comprise a fraction of tennant's
extensive audio drama and audiobook
catalog
his participation in audio who actually
dates back to before
christopher eccleston rebooted the role
in 2005.
tennant played a non-leading part in
2001's doctor who called it
a story involving nazis who somehow
gained access to the tardis at the
conclusion of world war
ii doctor who has not yet produced a
video game major crossover success just
yet
but just like james bond marvel comics
and other major franchises with similar
longevity the beloved series has been
churning out video games for pretty much
as long as video games have existed
this brings us to doctor who the edge of
reality
the game's official website describes
edge of reality as a reimagining of
2019's doctor who the edge of time
a vr game for console and pc where edge
of time features the 13th doctor played
by jody whitaker reality includes both
her
and david tennant as the 10th doctor
according to the game's official website
edge of reality will see the doctors
address
a threat to all of reality it pits the
player against
daleks weeping angels cybermen and
various lesser known but equally deadly
intergalactic baddies
as far as tenant goes it's basically a
continuation of his already extensive
catalogue of who-related voice-over work
but the jump from audiobooks to games is
significant for his fans
you can't play an audiobook after all
you need my voice in particular
the cleverest voice in the room
everybody's got a podcast these days
including our man david tennant his
podcast featuring the uninspiring name
david tennant does a podcast with began
in 2019 and has been running every week
since this series of hour-long
conversations with tennant's fellow
famous people is a delightful project
for tenant fans of all stripes
notable guests include u.s politician
and activists stacy abrams
author neil gaiman actress elizabeth
moss former doctor who star billy piper
and many others unsurprisingly tenants
got a knack for cultivating engaging
discourse
david tennant does a podcast with plays
out in roughly the same playful spirit
as mark maron's wtf
the host and guest take a seemingly
unscripted
casual journey through the latter's life
career ideas attitudes and
anecdotes plus any other subjects they
stumble into
tenant hasn't been in the podcasting
game as long as marin or
many other well-known podcast hosts with
similar sensibility
but tenant makes up for his lack of
experience with his easy-going nature
disarming charm and engaging scottish
accent
by no means did david tennant drop off
of television after doctor who
in fact for certain demographics doctor
who might not even be the program for
which he's most famous
david tennant voiced the lead role on
ducktales a celebrated reboot of the
1987 cartoon of the same name
if you've seen duck tales in its modern
incarnation and didn't recognize david
tennant you don't need to feel like a
dum-dum he appears in the role of the
billionaire mallard scrooge mcduck
the reboot has been met with an
abundance of praise
a major feat in any case but especially
impressive when one considers the fact
that people
love the 80s ducktales series at the
risk of blasphemy
we're going to go ahead and say the new
duck tales doesn't just earn that praise
it might surpass the original cartoon
the humor and storytelling can keep
adults in the room interested without
alienating any kids
the cast is star-studded and most
importantly huey dewey
and louis don't emulate their uncle
donald's unintelligible squawking
instead donald's nephews sound like the
famous comedians who do their voices
that is seriously a major improvement i
promise
i won't let anything bad happen to you
the miniseries good omens starring the
one and only david tennant burst onto
amazon prime in may of 2019
based on the 1990 neil gaiman and terry
pratchett novel of the same name
good omens involves a demon played by
tennant an angel played by michael sheen
their unlikely friendship and various
factors pertaining to the biblical end
of all life in the universe the cast
also includes jon hamm
miranda richardson and francis mcdormand
who portrays god
while good omens is not as culturally
prevalent as some of tennant's other
work
it was a slam dunk in terms of quality
critics almost
all got a real kick out of it meanwhile
author neil gaiman has said he found the
experience of
making the series wildly educational
especially in regards to his
professional transition from full-time
wordsmith to television showrunner
in a roundabout way that means we have
david tennant to thank for whatever
success is enjoyed by netflix's sandman
series on which gaiman serves as
executive producer
during the covet 19 pandemic people
discovered all kinds of awesome
activities you can do without going
outside you can watch movies you can
watch television you can read books you
can play board games
and that's pretty much everything as for
things you can't do
well you can't film a television series
about traveling the circumference of the
world in a hot air balloon
if that's your objective you're going to
have to wait until the pandemic is over
or at least has subsided significantly
the eight episode limited series
around the world in 80 days took a
pandemic mandated production pause back
in march 2020 and resumed shooting in
november
this tv adaptation of the 1872 novel by
jules verne stars tennant as felias fogg
the gambling protagonist appearing
alongside leone banish as detective fix
and
ibrahim coma as pasperto it looks to be
a whimsical and exciting
updating of the classic story and the
talent in the main ensemble is seriously
impressive
it releases in late 2021 there's a
pretty significant problem with our
collective preoccupation with major
streaming platforms
namely if anything cool or interesting
comes out on one of the lesser-known
services we might not find out about it
until months later
so if you didn't notice david tennant's
turn as convicted serial killer and
really really creepy dude dennis nelson
we can't blame you the three-part 2020
series dez is available on the
little-known platform
sundance now it's well worth seeking out
however even if it does mean signing up
for yet another streaming service the
searing drama got some pretty positive
feedback
with tenet's performance praised as his
most unsettling and
upsetting to date keep in mind one of
tenant's most famous roles happens to be
kilgrave a homicidal abuser with mind
control powers
still the critics urge us to believe
that next to his depiction of nilsson
kilgrave comes off as well adjusted and
socially acceptable
we shouldn't define tennant's career or
even judge his artistic instincts based
on a handful of roles cherry picked off
a cv that has been steadily expanding
since 1988 of course
but it is a pretty funny coincidence
that we recognize him primarily as
either a happy-go-lucky fantasy
character like the doctor or scrooge
mcduck
or as a homicidal sociopath like nilsson
or kilgrave
the public seems to prefer david tennant
as one extreme or the other
and it seems he likes taking those
over-the-top roles too
the coronavirus pandemic had a
disastrous effect on every industry
including the entertainment industry
massive delays were put on several
productions in order to help stop the
spread of the disease
and it was a difficult situation to try
to adapt to and film around
thus it isn't exactly surprising that we
didn't get a ton of notable pandemic
films or tv shows either but
a few did make it out of creative brains
and into existence
staged is a perfect example of this
stage stars david tennant and his good
omens co-star michael sheen
as exaggerated versions of themselves
that's right this is one of those
fictionalized real people affairs
allah keanu reeves and always be my
maybe
it's called vice breaker it's like truth
or dare but
a little more apocalyptic in staged
tenet and sheen are set to star in a
production of six characters in search
of an author by luigi pirandello but the
production faces an indefinite delay due
to the pandemic lockdown of pretty much
every stage in europe the pair of actors
decide to rehearse and cast the play
over zoom
as viewing experiences go staged
resonates like a digital british version
of curb your enthusiasm
check it out and we'd encourage you to
go in without doing too much reading
about it
there are some incredible guest
appearances that are great surprises
the disappointing fate of marvel's first
attempt at putting the marvel cinematic
universe on streaming television
has been well documented as a result
it's easy to forget there was a time
when kevin feige would have been
crazy to act like netflix's marvel
output didn't count as canon mcu
material
the first season of jessica jones was
particularly well received and tennant
deserves
significant credit for this turn of
events let us not forget that back in
2015 the only mcu villains anyone
considered worth a darn were loki
fellow netflix baddie wilson fisk and
tennis kilgrave often referred to in the
comics as the purple man
as kilgrave tennant inverts the quirky
charm he wields as the doctor and stuffs
it into a sociopath that jessica jones
combats throughout the latter two-thirds
of the season
kilgrave ceases to be a series regular
following the initial 13 episodes
however and while we'd like to make a
case that kilgrave's exit doesn't serve
the show's larger story and other
characters we can't
despite the quality of tenant's
performance jessica jones made the right
call in keeping kilgrave out of its
second season
but in an alternate universe scenario
where the folks in charge of the mcu
decided to do more stuff with kilgrave
marvel fans
would probably be talking about david
tennant more often
and we've seen comic book characters
come back from worse so we've still got
our fingers crossed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]